six-time all-star Mike Trout back here
in the Rich Eisen show how you doing
Mike feel good health so I am hanging in
there um what did you do to stay fresh
while you were on on the disabled list
Mike uh I go to field every day you know
get my work in I not going to workout in
and then that's still throw run and do
as much as I can as you stay in that
baseball shape and in terms of your your
thumb injury how did that affect your
video game playing Mike you have to put
that one on hold Tom it actually it
actually was give good therapy you know
it's a move that thumb around get that
you know that uh you know that motion
back and you know being out of the game
for a month and a half
you can't simulate a full baseball game
unless you're you know we're actually
playing mm-hmm so it's sort of like B
button therapy is that what you're
saying I said you know it's likely if
you play Playstations good like when
you're moving around like the joystick
mmm Mike Trout joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show so as we are in the
midst of this season right now with
Houston so far in front but you your
team is in the mix in the wild-card race
what is Mike Scioscia saying to you that
that I'm sure you may have heard before
in the past what is he saying to the
team right now if it's got a you know
keep pushing I'm going to tell you one
game at a time you know we can't look
ahead of ourselves when we can't look at
the standings or even the WOD color we
got a we know I obviously Houston is you
know far in front but you know the
wildcards right there in reach who's
going to play our player game not try to
do too much and start there and yeah
sorry you went so what what what does so
should do that he seems to he seems to
bring out the best in a team that may
not have a big name in terms of boldface
name talent that folks across the
country know quite like your name Mike
um ya know he's uh he can change the
game a lot you know uh either with you
he's you know he's around in you know
late in the game just to move guys
around just doing a little things you
know getting a guy over on a pond you
know whatever you know he thinks that we
need to do you know he does spend great
growing up there in New Jersey who was
the guy that
when you were growing up you were
idolizing that you wanted to be like
Derek Jeter number did you ever tell him
that what's that did you ever tell him
that I had telling personally but I'm
pretty sure you know Cleo with all the
media around yeah so say uh so he knew
that you were somebody so what what
about Jeter as a kid there in New Jersey
that attracted you to try to be like you
know just uh the way he carried himself
on the field the other shortstop another
kid yeah I just loved that was obviously
a Phillies fan but you know Yankees just
you know to wake yourself and all the
championships you only uh you know
leader on the field so all the Phillies
fan cuz it's your in southern New Jersey
is that what is that laughs about you
know twenty minutes from the you know
Philly so it's a really sportsman no I
know that up I know you're an Eagles fan
so what do you think of Carson Wentz
year to coming up I love him you know
he's good dude okay pretty good hard you
study see he works hard in the offseason
they work at hard to get better each day
every day yeah obviously I talked over
here and there but yeah I'm really
excited about see what he talked to him
about just small stuff you know hunting
he likes on so I talk too much it takes
a lot honey but you know he's locked
into camp you know you try to stay away
for a bit okay so you're gonna let him
be but when it all comes down to it you
hit him up before a big game like
against the Cowboys the Giants or
something like that ah yeah it's to my
text yeah not too much uh like uh you
know what is definitely you know I'm
doing a weekly yes I started peace
apartment row okay so should I take that
to mean that Mike Trout you do not have
Carson Wentz on your fantasy football
team to try and influence anything like
that um for sure I'll definitely drop
sure okay
when does that take place when is your
fantasy football draft take place this
year Mike yeah I think we haven't said
it yet but you must shove it up so yeah
you know it's not a pretty fun time
priorly September okay so we treatment
we can September who's in this league
just focus on the team yeah yeah there's
talk about ten people on the team so
okay
um what's your team name do you have
something all picked out can we help you
on that front ma uh you guys could help
me for sure
I don't have one this year um I remember
when I was last year you don't remember
what your team name was last year no I
wasn't really that good but I definitely
thought you know I was having tough
weeks put it that way
I would score you know 130 in my
opponent would score 140 so uh so you
are you are fallible when it all comes
down to Mike you are just like all of us
we have success and I obviously want to
be you want to be number one and you
can't control it you know things do get
banged up you know people have big years
that take chances on people it's you
know it's the twice fun okay so if you
got the number one overall pick who do
you take who would you take it out
picking uh Antonio Brown sure really
yeah okay the Angels have a PPR League
where you get your er so that's always
so as per tradition okay all right so I
got taking atonia gotta take the big
receivers have to okay they go quick and
then you take a chance on running backs
so it's like Zeke Elliott somebody like
whatnot no one drives ich weiß I can't
have any other boys on the same very
Cowboys on the team I'm talking average
I won't build reform so see Oaks wound
round you can't mix your fantasy and
your real living interests no
interesting Mike Trout here on the Rich
Eisen show a couple more minutes there
from from Cleveland Ohio who's a
toughest pitcher you've ever had to face
toughest pitcher I've ever had to face
[Music]
you know I haven't faced him in a while
but you know when he moved in nationally
that's pretty happy but uh probably
Scherzer sure just nasty why is that uh
this is you know he's got all kind of
pictures I go in every which way and he
like those 100 so it's uh it's tough to
pick up mm-hm and if you had if you had
your druthers if you could wave a wand
Mike Trout and change a rule in Major
League Baseball what would that rule be
um
I don't know if it would be a rule but
find a way to short the game a little
bit you know it's uh we played a we
played a game on Sunday that was two
hours and 13 minutes which was
unbelievable it was pretty fast and then
we played you know obviously last night
you know for half hours so anyway
destroyed the game well why was it why
was it 2:13 was it uh the pitching is
that what it was yeah yeah you know just
on strikes and um you know quick outs I
don't you know I thought honestly I
don't know you know what top of my head
with what it could be
but you know like last night we went 11
innings and was you know four and a half
hours so so you won't know what it could
be would you be up for a pitch clock I
mean is that something I got for you
know how obviously as a player as you
know as a position player I would I want
to be against it but you know you got
guys here on your team better pictures
and they would be against it so the you
know kind of you know back and forth to
that well what about making a rule that
you can't step out period that you're in
the batter's box that's it you can't
step out what about that um you know
they've been doing a thing with another
one foot in one foot out
they can't you know get that can I get
out fully um yeah hitting zone so it's
uh you want to you know be able to get
up there and you know be yourself you
don't have to you know be a strict rule
that you gotta stay in the box you got
to worry about getting a hit you know
it's a pretty hard hit so a couple more
minutes with Mike Trout here on the Rich
Eisen show do you feel an extra
responsibility uh for because you're a
face of this game because you've got
people children of all ages trying to
get a piece of you before you go to the
game and then obviously with the sport
battling with other sports for
popularity that the fun aspect of it
needs to be brought to the fore do you
feel any extra responsibility on that
front Mike uh you know I go out there
and you know I try to do whatever I can
to you know get the fans more involved
um you know I get a chance to see if I
see somebody you know outside of the
ballpark I try that you know get you
know say hi to them and you know if they
come up to me and get a picture whatever
you know I want to go out there and be
the best person I can be
that's role model for kids and you know
for all ages it's uh you know I want to
your Ottoman goal is it you know you
want fans come to the field to watch the
play and you know with all the other
sports out there that are you know doing
great you know you want to have you know
I have the same publicity event as well
okay last one for you are you a game of
Thrones guy Mike I am NOT a game of guy
I just mark the Garrett Richards is he's
trying to get me to get into it but I
don't know if I can so what's your name
be show to me show you know what I don't
really watch that many piece of TV shows
so you don't you know you know no III
watch praise my last TV show is Prison
Break so well I mean that's back I mean
they they brought a pack they brought it
back that's nice it's good I like it
okay what's the last movie you saw then
last movie I saw was I think it's called
the house the new ones and theater with
a Will Ferrell okay yeah yeah so that we
got to bring you on a feed on T I mean
that's interesting normally baseball
players you got a lot of time to be in
hotel rooms or flying around I mean what
do you what do you a coupon your time
with Mike uh you know like you know when
I have chance to go you know lunch and
go out you know cousin I don't really
you know didn't watch TV you know uh we
got to get to you who's will go on a
computer that's around them to Peter
okay um you know nothing crazy yeah
everyone's a lot I try to get into a you
know TV show but if it doesn't you know
appeal me first step to episode them you
know now watch this so okay well I'll
get locked in Game of Thrones I thought
you'd be you'd be in that direction but
I would I would highly recommend it Mike
sir yeah before tonight's I'm going to
try to get into that before it gets
spoiled for you and then we've got to
put our minds together here on the show
for your fantasy team name I mean that
should I mean let me know Tina should it
play off your last name because
obviously trout is something you could
you know have you ever eat whatever you
want what do you think Brockman I mean
we got something over there I'd have to
open the phone lines and let the fan
khana we do that help out here at all
right like if we if we let our perfect
you know we're on
angels radio out in Anaheim in Southern
California well you know we're kind of
like brothers on that front and we can
help are sure you get me give me some
some choices and I'll pick the best one
I think that's doing sure let's do it
Mike all right good luck tonight and
Beyond will chat with you down the line
I thought yeah thank you that that is my
truck the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you liked
that video be sure to download our app
and I'll be sure to help bnfl figure out
what it catches